dans quelques jours toi les enfants
partirait ensuite je vous rejoindrai 11
libre
oui oui oui c'est toi qui veut la
racheter bon je peux pas parce que j'ai
pas du tout les moyens si parce que
c'est moi qui vais te donner large
et à la fin de la guerre on fera un
échange inverse sur maps
merci
voilà l'été chez toi
on dirait qu'on est des voleurs voleurs
ou faire la malle contraire on au
service
ce fan sur scène là c'est pas réussi à
prendre le train les allemands contrôler
tout le monde ne vous inquiétez pas
monsieur le maire vous allez rester que
je suis ton autre une solution
à ta place je ferais attention je
recommanderais votre travail attention
quoi alors il comprend vos questions ici
on est bien le coeur tu me payes
conviennent dix ans la même chose
puisque paul denis avant
vous allez enfin pouvoir travailler ceux
des pionniers de ce nom ce [ __ ] tu
me fais travailler sur des bijoux volés
aux 8
soyez raisonnable on était au travail
mais c'est la vie
santé
ce que je fais c'est pour toi tu
comprends ça c'est pour nous protéger
nous
ça
vous avez de la chance la chance qu'on a
guère
ça ne dure pas qu'il faut
on vit une période de chine
vous n'auriez jamais dû proposer cet
outil avant m'avait rien et veut tout
[Musique]